just a quick heads up some of the topics
that we will be discussing this episode
are quite graphic and uh quite grotesque
at times uh this is mainly about chris
chan and the history of chris chen um so
it's all about it yeah it's uh and it is
a very disturbing story i would not
recommend chromecasting this to the
entire family yeah don't watch this with
your family watch this with headphones
if you have to
avoid it if you're not you know if
you're a little bit squirmish there's
some sensitive topics included yeah um
and also we apologize if we say the
wrong pronoun for chris uh we're not
doing it intentionally we mean no ill
will and uh yeah thank you so much enjoy
welcome to this episode of trash taste
i'm connor and i'm here with the boys as
usual joey and gantt and today we have
an interesting guest a rather unusual
one i might add as well gino samuels hi
do you know how you doing i'm okay
okay just okay i'm very okay so there's
probably a lot of people who don't know
uh who you are or what your work is some
people might be familiar with what you
do uh you do a youtube series uh on the
very notorious and infamous christian
yes i do
it's a very extensive series
from what um can tell so yeah obviously
there's uh if you don't know what chris
chan is or the law behind chris chen
it's a very uh
strange tale of the internet um and one
that i don't feel qualified to talk
about
how would you
explain what you do to somebody who
doesn't understand anything about
christian or the internet essentially
okay well
i talk in depth about christian and if
you don't know christian is a certain
person who has received a lot of
attention over the years from various uh
online forums and online groups
for his and then later her unusual
actions
and um
that's a very brief introduction a very
simplified introduction there
yeah also has been bullied a lot yeah um
so yeah um
i guess you could say he's um
he's kind of like the forerunner of of
several online online groups uh several
online um i guess um
i don't know what you what yeah
it's so difficult to like
describe like what he's all about right
you kind of have to go chronologically
year by year to like really get the full
story yeah so
this is all going on because i had not
heard of chris chan until like i think a
few months ago where kind of introduced
me to one of your videos
and i was because he couldn't believe
that i hadn't heard of chris chan as
someone who had been on the internet he
was just like what
how have you never heard of chris
jackson you've got spending youtube
since which year now 2000 20 2007. so
basically the start of youtube yeah i
found it
you know how dare you be on this how
dare you be on this website and not know
anything about christianity because like
i knew of things associated with chris
um you know which will obviously get
into later in the video but like i when
i heard the name chris chan like
obviously you know knowing because i'm
japanese right so
something chan yeah yeah oh it's just
like a character or like something like
that and then when i realized that chris
chan was an actual person yeah i was
like oh okay now this completely changes
things so so the reason why this episode
came about my gino is here today is that
uh i've been watching gino's series now
gino does um
well
a kind of a mountain task of documenting
everything and i think what i'm saying
on 59 right now is that right yeah so
you have made 59 uh
roughly around 30 to 50 minute video 50
minute videos how many hours of content
have you made do you even know of course
many people have calculated already it's
over 40 hours i've been over the hours
so this is a 40-hour documentary um you
know michael jordan is eating his heart
out right now you know the last dance
ioja you know
40 hours of content and it is just this
very fascinating look into and a side of
the internet essentially it's like a
really interesting just like case study
isn't it just like a person on the
internet and and i think i it's just so
there's nothing like it on the internet
and to have just such material like the
the sheer scale of it is really daunting
and trying to convince someone to start
watching because the way i try people
into uh christian this whole thing is
not because i don't particularly care
about what happens but it is almost like
a tv show at this point
which we can also get about later
whether that's ethical or not and you
know what not but you know i get my
friends into the documentary i'm like
please watch this it's insane like when
you like introduced us to gino's
documentary at your place that one time
and i saw that there was like 45
episodes at the time i think i was like
oh is this what it feels like to like
try and get someone into one piece no
i was about to say the exact same thing
because
this is like i saw i saw the episode it
was really interesting and i look at the
rest of the episodes and just the sheer
length i'm just like oh oh no yeah it's
like i know
i know like because like
just from watching episode one i was
like oh this is so interesting i want to
watch more but just like the sheer
amount just made me kind of fall back a
little bit yeah oh my god i think i
started watching your series around
episode nine or ten
um and that's when i started watching
basically whenever you uploaded them
and uh yeah it's been one of those
things where the longer it gets the
harder it is to convince people to start
because it gets so daunting i think what
happened the evening i showed these guys
uh the the series is that we had like
been drinking a bit yeah and we were
like what should we watch and i was like
i know the exact thing to watch at like
midnight let me let me put it on yeah we
finished watching all the super monkey
ball speed runs and we were like what
else what else can top that chris and
connor was like watch this
so we started watching it um
i don't even know how to begin talking
about this topic because it is so
difficult to explain if the viewers
don't know anything and i imagine the
viewers don't know much um
how would you describe
chris to someone who has no idea who
chris is okay christian is an autistic
individual who
who through the process of bad parenting
and
their own afflictions um cause
themselves to
both become
a subject of bullying online and also in
turn
um
they they did not learn
to avoid the trolls
on the internet and by by uh addressing
them all the time only brought them into
into a bigger bigger mess it is just a
case study of what not to do on the
internet right yeah almost every single
aspect it seems like for me from an
outsider because i think out of the
three of us i know the least about this
topic and it just seems from what i can
garner it's kind of like the perfect
storm of someone who is very susceptible
susceptible to
what people say about them on the
internet and being trolled and just kind
of the worst patrols possible egging
them on yeah and you just see the result
from that yeah
and uh that's
i mean it's it it says a lot when you
can make 40 hours of content and you're
not even up to date yet are you with the
full story not even close yeah i think
the there was obviously people might
know a lot about the recent news that
happened um as uh chris chan or uh
christine uh
um how do i even say this this is i'm
like afraid to like say it out loud uh
had you know a lot of people like their
mother um unfortunately chris
i i'm trying my best to say this without
getting demonetized a lot of people like
them
but i think chris christie particularly
likes
another level yeah
but the reason why it was so it was
covered in like a lot of mainstream
outlets because you're so
distinguishable
it's like you know chris uh chris
christine had a
sexual intercourse uh with their mother
who uh i believe has dementia is that
correct possibly possibly okay i don't
know but when you see it it's very old
right very clips it's very concerning or
i think around 80 now yeah and you know
it's obviously uh incest is illegal and
uh
the fact that
it is just insane yeah it is and quite
frankly it's it feels like uh
the worst timeline to be on um it felt
like you know
we can get into it later
what happened after but
how how do you you know when you start
to
introduce the topic of uh christine how
how do you talk about it to people who
have like no idea who want to know about
it
in a sense that okay you've given the
basics of
who who chris was back then and uh you
know how it all started but
how do you describe the documentary that
you make
uh it's a it's a deep dive into into a
certain
individual that um i guess for for the
most part chris was mostly known for for
the videos on youtube for a very long
time but then i started exploring their
uh quickie which is their their own
dedicated
wiki based on like everything they do
yeah and i've found so much amazing
information and interactions and content
which um gets ignored a lot on youtube
so i i decided to compile as much as i
could as much interesting stuff as i
could into video form to make it more
digestible on youtube and so you just
read all this stuff you're like this is
so interesting i want to repackage it in
a way that is more accessible right yeah
wow so how did you get involved in this
initially like
initially i wanted a video series like
mine to exist but no one had it around
so i decided to make it yourself yeah
yeah fair enough fair enough
no because like i i i guess what uh what
what uh motivated you to get into this
kind of because it seems like there's an
entire culture around chris chan right
now
historians chris
christorian is a person who knows pretty
much everything about it was a part of
christopher
i just couldn't imagine someone on
ironically being like i am a christian
yes professional
yeah
do you i mean are you technically one do
you refer to yourself as one or does it
does
identify as a christian people people
refer to me as the go to chris turin at
the moment yeah
it sounds
contempt when you say that
it's a burden i must bear
you know those memes where it's like the
people holding up like the world the
army and it's the they're living like
peacefully at the top it's like gino
samuel
i feel like there's some aspects because
you do seem almost you know you you hate
hate many aspects of it is that fair to
say um
i wish there was something more to my
identity rather than being a christian
right right of course you know but yeah
of course i can't blame them because it
is like the thing that i'm most known
for at the moment at least yeah it's all
it's also it is just so i think when a
lot of people see that you've made 40
hours or nearly 60 episodes on something
they do think
uh what drives a man to do such a thing
to make 60 episodes and i think if i
remember correctly when you've been
doing this um your channel got deleted
at some point right yeah so your channel
is called geno samuel 2.1 plug link in
the description um so i think because it
got deleted during the first one is that
correct yes you know samuel 2 was
terminated for bullying and harassment
right and that was for the christian
episodes that was the christian episodes
i was up to part 12 at that point yeah i
think this yeah i think i remember this
happening and i thought you were gonna
quit right at that point at some point
no yeah i did quit um actually made part
13 and then released it on uh on a
different video hosting platform but
then after that i decided you know what
i'm just not going to do this anymore
yeah yeah because what i want to know is
did you know what you're getting
yourself into when you
well at around part five i got already
10 000 subs on on youtube so for that i
made a q a video right answered some
questions and uh people asked how long
do you think it's going to be i said i'm
probably going to get up to date around
part 15.
so
i really had no idea
well yeah because it's just insane that
you know because like
because again i've seen a couple of your
episodes right and it's and it's just
insane because it's like one episode
isn't just talking about like one
core thing it's right it's like it's
just a compilation of all the things
that just happened in chronological
order so like like on average like how
long does it take to make one christian
episode uh from the start of writing to
the publication maybe three to four
weeks
oh my god i mean yeah like i can't think
of the amount of research that has to go
into right because like
yeah yeah yeah what is your research
process for this i wouldn't even know
how or where to start do you talk to a
lot of people in the community do you
ask them hey what happened if you're not
sure or like what is the whole process
um very rarely i do talk with someone
but i mostly go through the quickie and
then the qb farms
kiwi farms is a certain uh website
which is
which is focusing on discussions around
people online who do um laughable things
and
are affectionately or
unaffectionately referred to as lol cows
yeah because there's a whole website
called lol as well right which is
separate
that's a different thing yeah so
definitely a different website but that
is like the type of person generally
someone who just makes a lot of drama uh
does a lot of very questionable things
yeah my understanding of uh like uh kiwi
farms and local was always just like a
place where people go to like talk drama
about certain people and like yeah where
i feel like four channels just
unfiltered garbage that is sometimes
funny but also extremely questionable i
feel like uh lol cow cube if i'm very
centered on the creators online and very
much about people who are doing stuff
online whereas four challenges anything
yeah anything goes yeah but wasn't was
it correct me if i'm wrong wasn't kiwi
farms started
like for chris like to document chris
yes yeah yeah it was originally called
wow quickie forums
did you not know that i did not know
okay well that's well there you go so
yeah
ladies and gentlemen so yeah it was
originally called quickie forums and uh
the reason it's it um developed into kv
forms was because it was during uh
during a certain dry spell of content
from from christian when they were not
being active online for like a year or
so
people started making sub forms about
other people who are similar to chris
and then after a while they decided to
abandon the quickie forms and then
get a new domain and call themselves
kiwi farms which is apparently
um a result it's like it's actually
based on a mispronunciation that some
that some other lol cows said about the
quickie forms that they pronounced
that's how it started and so uh quick is
uh
is that just this christian western
christian western chandler which is the
name cwc
and that and that is uh essentially the
universe or like what is that what
christine bill is that
correct me on the the law there's so
much information it's very hard to keep
track yes chris uh started building
their own world um i guess during their
teenage years in the late late 90s they
developed this concept of quakeville
which is which is the city of quick
chris chan
i'm so there is there is
this is like this whole fantastical
world so fantastic you don't like
exactly do you know what sonichu is no
what do you want to explain what sonichu
is well i mean it's very i mean yeah
okay so i think quickball was actually
before sonichu so it was just like right
into there but yeah sonichu came about
as as a high school project
um chris was doing uh a design class
where he had to design his own cd
and he wanted to put on
sonic and pikachu a camera was a sonic
or pikachu and the teacher said you
couldn't put in any copyrighted
characters right so he decided to go
around that issue combined sonic and
pikachu into sonichu
very iconic meme online yeah so i found
out about the whole chris thing because
i knew what sonichu was because like
like you know being on all sorts of
internet forums back in the day like you
would just see sonichu like out of
context or you know used instagram yeah
i remember i saw it a lot i had no no
one i just thought it was a ripoff yes
right so i thought it was just like you
know one of those like funny memes that
someone created right and then i
realized oh sonichu is linked with this
person called chris chan and then that's
how i found out about the whole world of
chris and then i just went deeper and
deeper into the rabbit hole essentially
so you know when you watch your
documentary uh it starts out you know
uh i mean quite positive i'd say well
not positive but you know yeah i'd say
hopeful you know you you get a you get
introduced to uh uh chris at the time
and
it it kind of becomes this like you know
you get to see chris on tv uh when very
young right
when they won a competition
and you're like oh okay it's going
pretty well and then you start to get
into uh some very personal details about
chris which i always found very
concerning how they were like how did
you get this information because there's
when you get introduced to chris you you
learn about chris you learned that chris
is autistic uh that that chris is very
obsessed with games and stuff and then
somehow we we get a very detailed
explanation of chris's school life how
they had at the time uh multiple gal
pals as uh chris always refers to them
as
uh who then we are found out later they
were
the chris's parents were
asked the gal pals to be friends with
chris
so that chris had friends there was just
like so much
personal intimate detail that i didn't
even think i have about my own life yeah
right there was like uh a
medical record or something or a
psychiatric psychiatric evaluation right
so you showed this in the in your
episode of chris and i just sat there in
awe being like i don't even know where
mine is yeah if i have one
was this all self-published by chris um
some of it was the documents the school
papers the medical records were actually
like i guess illegally taken from their
from their property oh wow yes
um it was um it was a at a point much
later in their life around 2014 actually
there was a there was a troll who who
got into their their dumpster
and took out all the papers yeah [ __ ]
you know so people people have been
going to
uh chris's house and just dumpster
diving constantly just trying to happen
at least once i don't think many people
did that yeah it's kind of crazy
yeah but but but people do go there and
take updated pictures of the house for
example and they're right and their lawn
yeah yeah so as someone who doesn't know
much about chris chan as a whole topic
so like what are some of the most
notable things they've done
or that we can mention i i could say
that have like garnered them such a
notoriety online i mean at this point is
there anything that they haven't
mentioned
like
like like because for me i'm just like
okay so you talk about chris christian
being like one of the most documented
people probably in history at this point
and just seeing the first part of your
documentary i'm just like yeah i can see
that you know yeah like i i don't think
someone has had such intimate detail be
leaked or put out into a public space
before but like what are some of them
how did they gain notoriety in the first
place that's what i'm so curious about
um all started in 2007 when uh when
photos of chris were posted on 4chan i
think and then maybe somethingawful.com
yeah i remember that forum website yeah
so um people people connected the dots
and and uh showed off the pictures as
this is the person who created the
sonichu comics right and look at him
it's kind of like um like a freak
gawking
right right which is uh something awful
they used to just like post anything
that was awful quote unquote what they
thought they were just mocking yeah yeah
and that was the thing yeah so that's
how that started and chris noticed this
and started making videos addressing
rumors and correcting the record
yeah i believe one of the most
worrying things and is where you could
definitely tell this is going to take a
turn for the worst in the documentary
that you made um is that at some point
chris has this brilliant idea uh of just
releasing
everything yeah just right just
handwriting uh an absurd amount of
personal information probably penis
length included at some point in there
you know so yeah like the way that she
fights back is to basically dox herself
yeah which is a really strange strategy
yes
um yeah this was in response to the
encyclopedia dramatica page which was
made about chris chandler at that time
yeah and um apparently according to
chris um they were fed up because they
got a lot of details wrong so i wanted
to correct that and add context to
to to the information which just sounds
like a disaster basically adding a
footnote yeah yeah that's all the
information
you see like a fire and you're just like
let's just pour oil on this
no that's not how you butterfly here let
me help here
jesus yeah and and
part
he he called this
task um information overload
i love that i love that chris kept
calling it that it's like i don't think
that's how it works on the internet
maybe in person if you speak that i
would be like wait what
which i imagine he was kind of like um
thinking that the encyclopaedia dramatic
page would be like uh
a malfunctioning robot if you if you
feel too much information is it's gonna
explode yeah right you thought you
thought that maybe it's like feeding a
logic bomb to like an ai or something
right yeah so yeah it's like a plot to
like a movie or something
and uh encyclopedia dramatica again is
another drama website right
just uh encyclopedia of people who uh
have done well drama things and it's
literally just documented there's a lot
of yeah there's numerous websites that
are horrible like that oh yeah you know
uh
it's uh unfortunate that uh some people
go on there and then correct the record
about them yeah i still don't think
that's an act that's been done i don't
think mostly unprecedented most people
on there tend to not go on there and say
hey guys no no i didn't actually do that
i did this instead
and i think
so that's when that's like the
correct if i'm wrong that is one of the
biggest catalysts right so what
kickstarted
the fascination that people have with
chris yeah and
um
basically fed the trolls because they
received so much information so much
personal information about chris
and this included one particular drawing
of chris
and
their friend at the time their female
friend
being satisfied
in a certain way
yes
yeah that's that got a lot of attention
too obviously right
yeah
i think i think later on uh chris also
mentioned uh or christine at that time
uh mentioned that uh yeah they thought
that it was okay to draw sexual pictures
of someone because they weren't actually
taking like doing the sexual thing to
them or something yeah also chris chris
in a video or no chris in a in a
personal email said that they made that
drawing
in order to to um release their certain
urges
instead of acting it out in person wait
personal email to who personally emailed
to the female friend oh yeah
justification i do remember this in a
previous episode right yeah so they were
like oh i'm not going to do anything to
you that's why i'm drawing stuff so that
i don't do anything to you
which must be an extremely concerning
email to receive this person just like
the human yikes machine like well that's
the problem is that every time
when you watch this documentary when
you're reading about uh chris which is
just worrying in itself
every time you want to
give chris a chance and root for chris
yeah something happens where you're like
[ __ ] yeah every time she's that close to
getting in the w she does something
especially early on i feel like in the
start of the in the history you you very
much are rooting for
chris just stop
please just stop just getting off the
internet
and i think there was one turning point
for me where i was like for [ __ ] sake
uh when i was watching this and i think
it was uh i don't think they do this
anymore but chris at the time uh would
you say racist things
and was quite homophobic very often yep
and it was just to the point where i was
like
you know and i wonder how much of that
was due to the environment that they
were raised in
yeah i feel like
it raised very difficult questions where
it was like
is this your fault or is this your
environment's fault that you're a race
and you haven't been educated better is
this how you actually are where you're
like orchestrated by people well it's
hard to say you know because i feel that
uh they're a very impressionable person
i felt like you can definitely tell
whatever that was told to them as a
child uh was stuck with them quite a lot
right so i i it's a very conflicting
thing especially because chris does have
autism quite severe autism you do
you almost want to justify certain
things but then every single time you
want to justify well i'm sure it's you
know
something else happens yeah or you're
like for [ __ ] sake i am trying my best
to want you to do good be on your side
i'm trying my best here yeah you know
just i'm just like you know like that
domino meme yeah it is literally that it
is literally the massive domino like
chris chan draws sonic shoe and it ends
with sleeping with his
mother like i'm just like what happened
in between how did we get to this point
like because because you know it's i
don't even know where to begin about you
know because i do want the viewers to
kind of understand the certain
milestones if you will i would kind of
run through it just so much just so that
people can kind of who don't know
anything about it can understand
you know roughly the timeline so in 2007
this all started correct and
i don't know when the trolling saga
started but it felt like it lasted a
millennia
so
what's the trolling saga i feel like
there was like 30 episodes where it was
just trolling i mean yeah there was so
it was 30 episodes was like
in the span of two years
yeah
the problem is is that there is i feel
like uh the recent history of uh
christine has been very
not well not not i think he meant to say
cristory for the christophery
terminology there's not as much
essentially i feel like there was a lot
more recordings of trolling and stuff
and just the amount of it there's a lot
still but it's mostly confined to
to long twitter rants and like threads
on twitter and not not that many videos
which i guess is not not as entertaining
to most people so what kind of trolling
are we talking about here oh there's
some gorgeous stuff do you want to oh
sure um things really started to kick
off in around 2008 i guess when trolls
decided to pretend pretend to be uh
females online interested in chris
of course and that happened many times
actually
uh chris kept falling for it every time
which is unfortunate every single time
every single time yeah so you think like
even you know
it's like how many times they weren't
tenth catfish
it's like how many catfishes before
you're like i've seen this one before
this looks awfully familiar you know one
thing as well that is really concerning
about uh you know chris about this whole
documentary especially the earlier years
is just
how much chris wants to have sex
yeah i like that because i think that's
like the only way that you could fall
for catfish that many times right is
that like very uncomfortable once a girl
yeah how did he refer to girls at that
point because i remember a boyfriend
free girl
boyfriend free girl
[Laughter]
we need like an entire encyclopedia this
is like this podcast will not do it
justice hopefully what we can do is give
you a basic introduction and a quick
rundown of the important events and that
if you really enjoy
or you are extremely intrigued by what
you hear you can go and watch gino's
videos about it yeah but we'll talk
about it and yeah boyfriend free girl is
yeah one of my favorite phrases of all
time by the way that's uh that's
officially called a quick ism
these are all so these are all words
that are used by chris yeah invented by
chris kind of yum
it's it's like it sounds like a story
like a good story you know the the thing
that's very concerning about uh
christianity about the whole
thing especially earlier earlier on is
the way that he talks about sex is very
much uh
almost like a
watching a caveman speak about sex right
yeah where it's like i need i want sex
it's just like there's no emotion
intimacy you know there's no mention of
wanting to be close with someone it's
just i just want to have sex it's
impossible so much like i want to make
love it's more like i just want to
procreate yeah like vibe right yeah it's
really strange um and i think that's
that that also starts like you said it
starts trolling saga which has some
really disgusting points right which i i
mean so they start trolling with the
catfishing and then then it goes
we're not at the discussing point yet oh
no well it depends on what it depends
what flavor of because you know i feel
like there's a little bit for everyone
in terms of disgusting
um what is this an idea
just a little something for everyone
whichever thing disgusts you the most at
some point chris has been involved with
it yeah like whichever thing whichever
thing disgusts you whether it be um
i think one thing that i think was the
first thing that happened that really
caught me off guard and i i knew that
this documentary was not going in good
places
um i can't remember this if this was the
first or what
there is
many of the trolls i think you correct
me if i'm wrong here they often when
they were pretending to be boyfriend and
uh girlfriend they would like convince
chris that they were like almost dating
is that right right and then they would
ask chris for videos
of him doing certain things at the time
videos and pictures yes close-up
pictures of certain body parts yes
um yeah
and i i just remember i was taking a
bath one time watching this documentary
i was just like cleaning you know just
chilling you know because you know you
have a nice bath in japan i was silly
and i just remembered it's like and then
chris uh bought the cake and then filmed
himself sitting on it and i was like
what
what so
you proceeded
so what so what was why did this all
happen i think
it's just a way to see you know
would chris actually do this
just just to challenge chris in a way as
well
and um
i guess this also comes as a as a
consequence to the state of the internet
at that time where where you could be
anonymous a lot more easily yeah it was
very open yeah kind of just sounds like
they were limit testing well it was like
that that year was like the wild west as
well where everyone it kind of came out
yeah
mid-2000s internet was terrifying yeah
that was oh my god yeah i remember my
2000's internet man
it was literally like the lawless place
yeah like because i think at the time i
was on i was mostly on new grounds at
the time yeah that place was truly like
you know if it was the wild west there
would be duels happening left and right
people getting shot down yeah and this
was for two years mainly the main mostly
two years and was this because
chris was just extremely active in
responding or was it because there was
just a lot more of it like a lot more
trolls than there is now is what was the
reason why there was just so much in
those two years do you think
well it helps that chris provided many
entertaining videos
so i kind of created content for them to
laugh at um there was this uh certain
group a very close-knit group called
the private villa of corrupted citizens
like i don't even know if you're making
you know it's like it's almost tragic
with like being trolled right now
it's sad that a lot of the trolls
sometimes just seem as pathetic as chris
sometimes yeah yeah you know i'm
watching this you're like i don't know
who's more pathetic the guy trying to
get chris rubbing a cake in his ass
video or chris yeah you can't i can't
decide how you feel when i'm like
talking about faye yeah yeah yeah what
i think chris law is in his own world
yeah definitely
evening weebs baby man here and today's
episode is sponsored by honey you know
how these podcast ads go we read the
spiel blah blah blah we will give you a
promo code at the end but this one's
different because this is an ad for
honey and a honey ad doesn't just give
you one promo code a honey ad gives you
straight up millions of free promo codes
i'm guessing you shop online and when
you go to your favorite shops honey will
just automatically fill in the promo
codes when you're at the checkout but it
won't just dump in one promo code no no
no no it'll dump every single promo code
it can find and then test them all in
second to see if one can give you a
discount and the best discount it can
find plus honey knows where to look for
promo codes that is hard to find if you
didn't know pizza is very expensive in
japan and i often use honey to get
discounts on pizza i mean recently i
just saved ten dollars in pizza two i
guess make it a normally priced pizza
anywhere else in the world so get all
the promo code you can at joinhoney.com
trash taste that's join honey.com trash
taste thank you honey for sponsoring
this episode back to the video so this
trolling group uh the pvcc which is
actually named after
a thing in sonichu
the comic series so chris made this name
up it wasn't the trolls um the pvcc was
also the name of their uh community
college
or the piedmont virginia community
college renamed as the private villa of
corrupted citizens because because to
chris that college um symbolized a very
dark time in their history because
because the dean
of of the school prevented chris from
from posting uh an attraction sign on
the wall asking or looking for a
girlfriend chris would often post signs
across the school and then also around
their area yeah just advertising that
they wanted a boyfriend-free girl
right yes wow it's very strange because
i think the lack of awareness is just
always the achilles heel
came to chris yeah and uh i believe for
example there was a period where chris
got kicked out of the mall
at least once yeah for putting up signs
well it wasn't signs was it was
loitering
loitering with like a money for a
boyfriend-free girl right yeah like
chris would approach people right at the
mall um yes they would as well and also
maybe throw throw a rock with the red
string attached
and try to like lure her girl
you're making this sound
it's called the red string of fate
oh right that's popular in uh japanese
culture yeah
so chris was literally fishing for girls
that was at least one one attempt at
that yeah okay and then uh
yeah chris was actually um very
infamously dog piled on by by security
guards and uh thrown in jail i guess for
for a little bit but then released and
then permanently or like temporarily
banned from the mall right the local
mall so yeah
that was an issue for chris because that
prevented chris from
from um
going to the go-to hotspot for
boyfriend-free girls
from like from an outsider looking in
you do kind of you want to feel
sympathetic towards this person right
because they are getting the worst of
online trolls right but at some point
you just you just hear a story about
something that they do and you're just
like what what is wrong with you like it
very much pushes the limit of
you know how much accountability
you put on someone yes uh especially
when chris does have like quite severe
autism yeah it's very difficult to feel
like
man if this was a normal person this
would be totally your fault but also how
much can you you know like i said
earlier there's so much factors of like
you can clearly tell the upbringing yeah
was uh questionable maybe
i don't know how good the parenting was
i mean i'm not a parent i can't judge
right
but you you have to learn some of these
things from somewhere right
i mean what for you was like the
sympathy line that like chris like went
over the line and just like nope like
there's no way i can root for you
anymore if they're if they're well where
are you we're at the sympathy line i
mean
i'm not personally i'm not very
sympathetic now yeah but um especially
not after the recent events
recently now it's like there's no
sympathy there
there's like all sympathy is gone yeah
the sympathy line is just like in the in
like the dust at this point but yeah
like i said remember i was watching it
and and there was parts where like i
genuinely felt like sympathetic towards
chris yeah i wanted to see chris do
better and then there was just a rant
about why chris hated gay people at some
point and i was like for [ __ ] sake
but was that orchestrated by the trolls
no no that was i believe a lot of them a
lot of the issues of
of upbringing with chris is the parents
who were very old when chris was
conceived the father was 54 the mother
was 40. so they were already old-timey
kind of people who didn't really
understand what autism was when yeah
right was diagnosed with it and they
were kind of afraid of um of letting
chris go to a to a special school for
autism or you know to uh treat it in any
way and just they kind of pretended that
it didn't exist and kind of tried it
right yeah yeah
i would be absolutely crushed if i found
out my parents asked someone to be
friends with me that would yeah i wonder
if that did affect chris at all if you i
don't admit did chris even view it that
way
eventually they found out yeah
but um
at the time it was they were very happy
was it was the happiest time of your
life as they stayed at many many times
during their high school yeah it's
almost
what's the back story behind this um so
chris had a lot of gal pals is that
correct yes
who are girls but not girlfriends just
friends who are girls relationships
as you as you would call it and you
would see a lot of the pictures of like
chris's earlier birthday parties would
be with these gal pals right later found
out that uh chris's dad had asked i
believe uh maybe their parents or them
to be friends with chris actually was
kind of an amazing situation where this
was
this was a later trolling attempt i
think in around
2015 or so
chris chris themselves tried to organize
a high school reunion so then they would
finally meet up with their with their
gal pals one more time
but
during this time trolls decided to
pretend to be gal pals
and stated in their emails that that
their parents only asked them to be to
be friends with them in exchange for
like money or good grades or whatever
and then chris asked their mother is
this true and then she answered yes
they just coincidentally got it right
jeez but like
i'm thinking like because even up until
the whole trolling saga point that i
think a lot of these trolls knew already
so much information about christmas
yeah so it's like did they get it right
coincidentally or maybe there was like
some hunch being like well you know it's
also really sad watching it's like
you're going um i attracted you you had
a question no no no no i was just i was
just saying like i wonder if it was
actually a coincidence or maybe they had
a hunch of some kind to be like maybe
the parents did actually do this and
let's just like run with the story
because it was a hint yeah that means um
how how likely is it for these gal pals
to be so close with chris honestly
honestly right right yeah
reality is sometimes harsh unfortunately
i i think one of the things that did you
just quote thanos
reality is
reality is often hard
be whatever i want it to be
i didn't i wasn't even aware because
i've never even seen the [ __ ] movie
you've seen the memes you've seen them
i've seen the memes i don't remember
them
you know subconsciously
that that meme was really rent-free in
my head somewhere
the one thing that i felt very sad about
watching this uh documentary is
chris's clear
nostalgia and almost want to be back in
high school yeah
and the fact that chris never grows out
of it yeah that's what really just felt
very sad watching because you know this
has been going on we have videos of
since chris is god knows how young and
going up and um just never changes and
always wants to be back in high school
where things were simple and had guts
was their high school life good probably
compared to now so they claim right
right bitcoin was great because they had
gal pals and um
yeah that's it really also i believe i
believe you know uh they used to
frequent the local game store an awful
lot as a child is that correct or is it
that one's i'm not too sure about right
personally um they well i mean i feel
like when you
people have a lot more patience when
you're a child
right and i felt that
chris had a lot of luxuries probably the
fact that people would probably you know
they wouldn't question a lot of things
and they would also look very patient
with some things i'd imagine that people
aren't really when you're an adult
people are kind of scared like there was
a whole
arc if you will with chris in the game
store yes
there's multiple arcs so chris you how
did this start with chris and the game
stall because you're trying to explain
this rough arc okay
chris went to a local game store where
they where they uh played games and um
bought games pokemon trading cards
pokemon train cars yeah yeah and i could
play you know games on the tv as well on
the on the wii at that time i believe
and that's where they met their female
friends
uh which they later drew you know
right in a certain way through a rock
yeah
so yeah in this game place um
chris really liked this this female
friend and got way too touchy several
times way too many times even though she
she addressed this in emails privately
but chris continued to do so
and um yeah eventually that relationship
fell out after the uh
the image was leaked by chris
themselves
it's like who is everything who leaked
all this information it's always crazy
it's always chris yeah
so yeah and after that point chris still
continued to go to the game store for a
little bit longer before
they start causing way too much trouble
with with the manager getting very
annoyed by their constant um hogging of
the of the tv right of the games
possibly even shouting racial slurs at
the african-american children
so
every single time you want to root for
chris
just so you hear something and you're
like for [ __ ] sake yeah [ __ ] you know
i get it if like you know chris tried to
like approach the girl you know to be
like yeah i just want to be in a nice
relationship
not in like a weird way kind of thing
and then they're just like no i'm i'm
going to do the worst thing possible to
try and move this
remove the relationship you have to be
racist towards kids really yeah really
it's it's it's like a it's like a comic
book villain at times you know it's
almost
it's like a it's like a darman video
right because like it's so textbook
racist or uh in some ways where it's
like you can't make this up no one would
do no one would act like this yeah and
sony would carry on carry on the game
store yeah so yeah they were banned
and after after about nine months i
believe chris made a video on youtube
addressing the manager of the of the
game store right uh thinking that you
know if you if you put his name in the
in the title of the video he would just
magically see it and see this video
addressed to him
well like well like the manager's real
name yeah
honestly yeah you know because people
just going onto youtube and just typing
out their full name and like made a
video about me yeah maybe it wasn't like
his name in the title at all was like
the the stock dvd like
sm q005 or whatever chris started the
video with this video is addressed to
the manager of the game store blah blah
blah and
please let me back i've learned my
lesson like that i remember this yeah i
do remember this right and the manager
was like no oh yeah that
like about half a year maybe after that
chris was convinced by a troll some gal
pal or or a girlfriend online to um go
back to the game store and and try to
get themselves unbanned
um
they actually recorded the conversation
privately on their person of course
because because chris's girlfriend
e-girlfriend at the time as far as they
knew thought it would be a very good
idea and like they would like be able to
uh
threaten the manager with like oh oh you
said this and i don't know yeah right
yeah uses blackmail tried to blackmail
right and then the manager said no and
just kicked him out again and i think
threatened to call the police and then
on the way out chris called the manager
a jew
and um
you know what i mean you see what i
mean jesus okay that happened right yeah
that happened and then
other things happened yes about another
year after that
chris um
chris went back to the store with with
their mother actually
and um this was after after their
elderly father had died already right so
they went back to the store because they
saw a new banner up on the store saying
under under new management or under a
new owner and they realized that the
manager of the store now became the
owner of the store and became angry
again they were kicked out and on the
way out uh the manager of the store was
run over by chris's car
twice
see the thing was not not accidentally
right like well the thing was
we're not really sure what was the order
of the situation but
both chris's mother and chris themselves
were driving the car and each took a
turn to run
it actually sounds like a looney tunes
right so i'm not sure who did it first
like did chris accidentally do it and
then swap oh your turn
this is your police mother
or
maybe they thought that
like
the second time the other person driving
was like uh cover for them you know like
right right you take them you weren't
driving it was me so then let's run over
them twice there but anyway yeah they
were both charged with uh manslaughter
no it wasn't manslaughter no no it
wasn't mass thought it was like grievous
barley harmon i don't know was there was
a shauna owner okay um the the owner was
okay actually and he actually
wanted the the charges to be dropped or
at least listened damn oh yeah what a
nice manager after someone ran me over
so we got racism homophobia hit and run
like is this person just speed running
hate crimes now yeah
there's more there'll be more she's
trying to like a hundred percent hate
crimes
like getting the xbox achievements it's
like a bingo list of crimes it is
shocking how many you can accidentally
commit when you're not really aware of
the original gamer
the completionist
oh gosh i mean
i mean some people might say that chris
might be the the first let's player in a
way
yeah cause chris chris did videos of
chris chris little big planet chris made
a video on little big planet back in
2002 or three wow and they were
narrating their actions over it which
makes like that's the last one like when
the first let's plays ever yeah holy
[ __ ] and and the uh and that review was
actually published in the the nintendo
game magazine
nintendo power wasn't it
yeah it was published wow actually
published actually chris had two things
published in nintendo power over the
course of their life it's like an animal
crossing video if i remember correctly
it was animal crossing yeah yeah it was
yeah
wow and they were talking about what
they were doing and uh one of the first
things that chris did during their
narration in that video was saying that
they were a high-functioning autistic
virgin this is all yeah this is
something that chris often mentioned
very often because i'm a high
functioning autistic virgin
which you know when you watch it it's
like what yeah you're just not used to
hearing that's like four words i didn't
think i would hear them next to each
other or someone's self-proclaimed yeah
right which is just it's it's and the
whole like i said there's arcs right
there's just and the game store is over
like 10 years i don't know it's quite a
long time if i remember about five years
yeah it's quite a long time storage and
also watching these uh this documentary
it's kind of because it's all in
chronological order
it's it's concerning how often stuff
gets revisited and chris tries again so
what other arcs are there
well like i said the trolling one feels
like it lasts forever yeah the initial i
mean the equation is always being
trolled with that it never stopped
though it didn't really but there was
like i feel like it was like the fourth
ninja war arc
just kept going yeah yeah
it's like the manga arc that you wish
ended like 10 years ago that just kept
on going and like you know there's some
really abhorrent trolling that was done
and again like some of it is so bad that
i do
still feel sorry for chris like uh you
know wouldn't he shove stuff up his um
you know his uh
member at the time
up his member did he do that or was it
his part it was it was the butthole
which isn't very good
yeah
but yeah this was a very unfortunate
very dark episode in chris's life where
where chris believed that their a
girlfriend at the time was being
kidnapped
by their evil brother or whatever
and um also their their playstation
network account was also being hacked
and held hostage so chris had to choose
which one would you prefer to save your
girlfriend or your psn account at which
um they chose chris chose the girlfriend
but by choosing so chris believed that
they would get both because he mean
because they made the right choice
like like a bible like
you made the right choice exactly yeah
the five pounds yeah it's the money of
the
the money of the bible you get both if
you pick the bible
but yeah during during the course of
this of this uh of this debacle um chris
was tasked with either i think burning
their sanitary medallion which they
which they fashioned out of a
like play-doh or a clay yeah very iconic
piece of
either either either burn it or
put it up their butthole
so
chris chose to you know cut it up into
smaller pieces first because it was too
big oh oh of course of course totally
don't burn it at that point you know
it's already destroyed but don't burn it
you can put it back together afterwards
what was the logic behind cutting it up
instead of burning it is ever explained
no
it's just like what if you're destroying
it why not
choose the option of destroying it
because you can still put it back
together right maybe what was that the
thinking maybe chris thought that they
didn't have access to matches oh i'm not
sure um we're just kind of ironic yeah
given sorry given what happens later but
yeah yeah
what happens
you don't know
i don't know i'm not sure it's like one
of the it's one of the most biggest plot
points in the whole story oh we haven't
even got to the plot twist
i'm so invested it's it's like one of
the like most well-known parts of the
story i might notice
maybe we'll talk about it it's in part
39 by the way
530. i remember because this was the
part that i was waiting for to happen
because i i'd heard so much about it and
i wanted to know i know it's insane it's
insane
so
yeah there's chris put the thing up
their butt and
filmed it and obviously in your version
you censor it for that um i i believe it
was like a skype call or something um so
so the person acting as as the
girlfriend and also the evil twin
brother
they were the same 13 year old boy by
the way 13 year old boy 13 year old boy
he's doing this
what so yeah
after after
the shoving
um they revealed themselves to be a 13
year old boy and that the girl never
existed which was just which distraught
chris there were other yeah naturally
yeah there were other members of that
the trolling group
in the call but but just listening and
you know being being muted but after
that they they came out and said jesus
stop like they knew yeah i remember this
yeah they knew that this boy went way
too far obviously yeah yeah it's it's so
disgusting that you know that only like
a sick kid would ask someone to do this
yeah when i was 13 i think i was just
playing jenga or something i don't know
what the [ __ ] i was doing i certainly
wasn't thinking about that i wonder how
do these kids do this that's like
throughout this thing it's almost as
much as chris was doing some really
abhorrent stuff yeah i almost find that
everyone involved was also
very guilty of doing some really heinous
things yeah and it felt like anyone who
went near
this like cesspit of drama was just
dragged into doing really horrible stuff
honestly it just sounds the entire thing
just sounds like a [ __ ] show like it's
like relatively and literally like it is
it is the worst part of the internet in
every aspect it shows every single
terrible thing a troll can do
it shows the terrible nature of feet
what feeding trolls does yeah you know i
i don't think there's
and that's why it's almost hard to look
away because it's so
fascinating such a magnificent train
crash right that you just like
it's like it's like the train crashes
and does 10 backflips and then lands and
then it catches fire yeah it's just
almost like everything that
it's just so insane and i think that's
why again you should go and watch gino's
uh video on it or videos wait well hold
on like you guys you guys like blue
balling me with this like point
i need to so there's the whole trolling
thing
i don't know is this the best arc so
yeah so yeah so so the so the trolling
with the with the fake girlfriends thing
went on for quite a while uh pretty much
until chris's father died right uh when
he was when this was two years right
about two or three years yeah so after
that they decided you know
let's leave chris alone
you know they've suffered enough i guess
i guess that was their there are things
yeah two years later i think we've done
enough damage i think this is enough
like no it's like you should have been
stopped at the medallion right shoved up
yeah so so there was a solid year where
chris didn't do much except occasional
facebook posts
uh yeah and then fast forward to 2014
where in the middle of the night
chris was i believe trying to make a cup
of coffee
and uh the extension cable which which
connected to their coffee maker uh it
was like draped over over the bathroom
door
and like the constant opening closing
like
damaged the wire yeah it caught fire the
house caught fire
yeah it was a you also have to
understand that at this time chris's
house is a hoarder's house yeah right so
you know when you hoard stuff your house
just goes up in flames yeah of course
that was the problem as the reason why
this was so jank and the reason why the
coffee machine was so [ __ ] to begin
with is because there was no floor space
right right and i believe there was two
or three cats
inside this hoarder's house
did the cats i don't know if the cats i
assume the cats unfortunately didn't
make it one cat dies
that's what's so sad about this is that
you know in some aspects you kind of
don't feel sorry that chris
ruined their own life you know because
you almost you know this is done by
yourself yeah but i think the the most
unfortunate part about this is
not only is uh our chris's parents and
dragged into all of this mess but also
pets as well yeah just like other you
know like innocent bystanders just got
involved you know this manager got ran
over you know there's many points in
this story that are so sad just for
again it's like a vacuum if you're
involved with chris in any way generally
not good stuff was happening
um yeah and the hoarder's house there's
pictures of it i'm assuming we can you
can show it on screen right it's totally
fine yeah probably fine it's fine this
is what it looks like it's pretty bad
it's very very so was chris the hoarder
or was it that chris was mostly not the
hoarder actually chris's room was the
most mother right it was it was chris's
mother yeah she was the hoarder and um
actually
actually uh resulted in the pretty i
guess infamous video of uh
of chris who after after posting a house
tour video on youtube
um
which is insane to think that you would
post a tour of that yeah right
for uh for a girl obviously right
girl as far as chris knew um
chris's father found out
and uh demanded that chris take down the
video off of the internet which was kind
of an impossible task
yeah and then during during the
recording session where where chris was
shouting at the camera and all the
trolls to take it down now now now now
now um chris's father walks in and they
have this little discussion
about um chris saying uh about um about
chris's father saying you know if the if
the health department sees this video
we're gonna we're gonna be evicted you
know you just you just you just stuck a
knife in our bags and killed us with
your video is what he said yeah so it's
very
jesus yeah crazy video on your own yeah
when you're watching this video uh i i
you have to watch the video to get a
real horrible sense of scale this it is
essentially like a jungle gym you can't
like even the camera doesn't you can't
see anything right junk everywhere
and it's just too zoomed in yeah so
every time you're like looking around
you can't get a sense of scale of
anything because it's just so much stuff
and obviously you know horde's houses
are uh basically just what fire hazards
i mean there's a reason why you get
evicted because you can't do that at all
that's exactly what happens right
cockroaches
also i believe the cats were also sick
at the time is that right or they would
i wouldn't be surprised you can't
they're healthy yeah they were later
there were other new later cats who
became sick in the house yeah right i i
remember watching a video when they
moved to the new place which was given
was it provided by the government uh
there was a there was a new temporary
rental place yeah that was provided by
the
house insurance uh
and uh yeah i remember there was a point
in this video where you could hear the
cat and it sounded like it was dying
it sounded very bad dogs too
the dogs as well right
no leave the animals yeah right it's
it's a horrible story you know and i
think it puts into it you often ask the
question of like how ethical is it to
watch all this stuff and document it and
talk about it is that something you
often struggle with when you're um yeah
making these videos i i do yeah yeah um
well i think one thing about your videos
that i could get is that it seemed like
you weren't it was it was just pure
documentation right you weren't putting
your opinion into it it was just pure
this is what happened and this is just a
pure documentation of things you can
already find on the internet yeah it's
kind of just like you know just laying
out the information and kind of leaving
it up to the viewer to make their own
opinions about the whole
case
because i think that's what really
attracted me to your videos is that yeah
again there was just no no input from
you but also made you a kind of a
mysterious figure yeah you always start
the video saying like who who is chris
what drives i'm like who's gino
why is he making this video
which is why i wanted to bring you on
because i really wanted to learn more
about you as well and what drives you to
make these videos because i feel like
you know it takes a it takes a mental
toll i imagine having to document this
stuff and there are some lines that you
have to say out loud because you narrate
chris's words
and i
there's some very funny out of context
clips of you being like just shouting
really funny stuff putting stuff up your
ass
at which point were you just like
committed to like i mean i mean yeah
yeah yeah
that way you were just committed to i
assume completing this thing i mean
you've gotten this far right i mean i
was committed since the beginning yeah i
imagine just i was i was not expecting
this to last this long unfortunately
yeah but
i do understand that some parts may be a
bit boring for some and just the
constant maybe facebook like
readings of of a facebook posts or
tweets for example which i do cut down
as well but
i find it interesting and relevant to
the story which is a which is a
kind of it's a kind of conflict for me
every anime has its filler off yeah
i find that's what makes your videos so
compelling is that it almost feels like
no stone it's left unturned like every
single thing is included is that fair to
say that you include pretty much
everything
not really oh really most things most
things things that are really not
interesting or not relevant to the
development of the story then yeah i do
skip over them so how much how much
stuff is you know when you you have the
episode yeah how much stuff in in
between like tweets or facebook posts is
cut like if you had to give like a ratio
of like how much information makes it in
to not in the video possibly about one
percent doesn't make it out
so nearly everything else goes in it's
like literally everything goes in all
right wow i mean it depends on on how
much detail i'm on uh how much time i
spend on it like for example if it's a
vaguely interesting tweet for example i
just mentioned that that chris talked
about this or like if it's if it's more
compelling if it's more interesting i
just read word for word most of it for
example so i spend more because i was
about to say like if you had said like
oh about twenty percent that would be
like jesus how much content
is there on this person like a worrying
amount right like i already watch your
videos and i go my god this is more
information than you know several
generation families that
have on the internet let alone just this
one single person oh god i remember what
what year did uh chris transition
2014 i believe right right yeah and it
is a very disturbing uh phase yeah
that's what i want to like once
there's a lot of stuff that chris
does and later christine they're very
like worrying i'd say right well that
happened a lot a lot what's what's the
line of worrying
i've already heard a lot of boring
things this episode
so how did it start do
we know that well how does that all ever
begin uh with chris the transitioning
yeah um
chris very early on exhibited some
interest in in being a female
um like for example writing on uh on
public posts in a troll created forum
which which which was made to appear
like a fan site for christian but
they're all just trolls yeah
yeah of course um chris said that
sometimes they thought that maybe life
would have been better if they were born
as a female but
since i was born with but since like god
delivered this package i must like feel
it i don't know
something like that yeah chris christian
a lot more more poetic than i do yeah
well of course of course
um then chris started leaking some some
uh chris was sending nude photos to
other other girlfriends
which i featured
chris trying on their mother's
on underwear bra as well right so that's
i was worrying as well yeah yeah and
then after and then after that uh
another
e-girlfriend convinced chris that maybe
they would feel better jogging because
they were very self-conscious about
their man boobs bouncing around so so
she suggested maybe chris should wear a
sports bra and then chris discovered
that they really liked the feeling of a
sports bra
and um pretty much never took it off
after that point honestly until until
they transitioned and started wearing
you know women's underwear full time
right right it's like um some people
suggest that maybe chris was influenced
by trolls saying
some some quotes exactly that uh chris
was convinced to become a female to
explore their feminine side right um
this is questionable no no one's really
sure how this happened but um yeah chris
started first identifying as like a
lesbian soul in male body something like
that okay right i'm not very well
educated on this stuff it's very uh i
try to but it is it's quite a lot of
information yeah yeah
and after after about another half year
or so they they've they fully embraced
the identity of of the new name
christine
and changed their uh gender officially
even on their driver's license so it's
so it's quite quite legit at this point
yeah and they do use uh gender
transitioning medication as well okay
right right yeah i i say concerning
because during the first uh phase it was
very much a diy uh transition it wasn't
the first phase actually that was that
was quite a bit after it was it oh yeah
i felt like that because that was what
stuck out to me what goes before diy
well chris chris decided to uh expedite
matters by by listening first by by
listening to binaural beats on youtube
what is binaural beats i
[Music]
is a type of like a humming noise that's
that's supposed to that's supposed to
influence the way your mind works and
kind of change you in a certain way like
for example it usually like it uses like
a certain frequency i believe that it
almost acts as like a type of hypnosis
right of sorts is it a lot of is it
[ __ ] is it
there is actually science behind is this
a well-known thing this is the first i'm
hearing of this no this is very much
like a music like is it really a real
thing i mean there is some science
behind it but like but the whole thing
of like hypnosis and stuff like that is
very debatable i mean binaural beats
making you like feel uncomfortable or
comfortable yeah i i can see that
happening but changing you from male
organs to females sexual organs yeah
chris was trying yeah chris was trying
to grow boobs boobs and then chris was
actually going to the actual uh
channel of these binaural beats and
asking the uploader will this will this
binaural beats video cause my testicles
to develop into ovaries or well would
they make another video about that or uh
answer no
but it's very sad because in some
aspects this is where other aspects of
the internet
failed chris right like this is this is
a predatory thing to and i don't know if
they encouraged or they said that yeah
you'll grow boobs from listening to this
beat that's [ __ ] but it's and also
when you're desperate enough as i
imagine uh chris was at the time
we willing to believe it i mean i'm sure
chris has fallen for more obvious stuff
with like because this was after the
challenging phase right right and uh
didn't chris end up in hospital uh for
trying to uh
so this is a very disturbing
thing um
they believed uh that the
uh
opposite sex organs were inside all they
had to do was cut it
open
and they did indeed do that right and
they ended up in hospital um what they
what they cut
was the uh was the space
in in between the uh the douche
right yeah i i believe that's yeah i
believe that's the way to call it yes i
think it's called the gooch i think it's
called the gucci gucci
gucci skin between the balls on the
board right yeah yeah they're good that
one pretty deep cut right they cut it
they're the bereal i don't [ __ ] know
i'm not educated on this i don't touch
that place often
it is the premium also called the taint
the tank
so that's the bit that's the space
between the whole and
i'm so sorry viewers i'm so sorry we're
using scientific terms here yeah chris
believed that in this space was where
their
labia would be if they were born as a
woman so they so they cut it open and
posted photos
they posted photos oh yes
what
wait of after the act like after they
come out it must look like a crime
like a war veteran now yeah just like
this this is a murderer do you know what
sound a man makes when they die i do
and i like it
they went to hospital for it right they
were very reluctant to go to the
hospital because they were infected
right
it could have been it was it was like
yeah from what i understand it was very
rewarding it could have like yeah no
[ __ ] because i caught like absences or
something and
died from it eventually but yeah
eventually trolls convinced chris to go
to the hospital and get it checked oh
the trolls convinced chris to go to the
hospital which is weird because then
later on i'd say from this point onwards
is where it used to be like kind of like
a almost torture hostage situation yeah
i was like i want to talk to you but i
want to keep you alive yeah yeah yeah
because a lot of the trolls and i
believe the uh especially what happened
a little later on as the founding member
of the kiwi farms right often would
financially look after chris
and would help manage chris's finances
right that wasn't it wasn't there like
later there was like a group of people
right people would offer they didn't go
fund me correct after the the uh
the watchmen or something was that what
they thought the watchman is a different
thing
this is insane
so these people who had originally were
trolling chris ended up then
supporting him supporting chris and
almost being protective over who can
have contact with right chris right
yes yes they were yeah it's weird right
because it feels like a hostage thing
yeah it's like i'm gonna feed you food
and take care of you but you're still my
hostage right like the weirdest cult
i've ever heard it's very strange yeah
the thing is is after after chris's
father died the main trolls behind all
that kind of stopped their trolling and
then
moved on to kiwi farms just like as an
observation kind of thing and looking
after chris but like the other trolling
that happened after that point was made
by other people which were not
affiliated really with the with the
original core because then there's like
tons of different factions of right
people who are obsessed with yeah so who
are the watchmen the watchmen was a
group
created a comic uh storm by frank miller
pretty poor at a movie adaptation
um anyway watchmen were a group which
were created for the sole purpose of
protecting chris
right right which which did not work at
all
they're broken up at this point when uh
when uh it was revealed that some
members of the watchmen were actively
involved with trolling curse oh my god
that's backstabbing the watchman well
this is why it's such a [ __ ] mess
like every single person involved is you
know
has questionable
motives yeah because i only found out
about the watchman from the the recent
events right um and there's like there's
like three or four other groups or
something that we're all involved
in all this stuff and they all have
their own names
when did documenting chris really reach
its peak of popularity
peak of popularity well now now it's
very popular yeah but you know before
this you know i definitely felt like
there was an increase people who are
benefiting and profiting off of chris in
many ways
uh by making content around chris
um in a almost harmful way yeah
definitely a more recent phenomenon
right right
i think
which is i feel like where it started
you know it was kind of improving yeah
and chris was not really involving much
and people were not really trolling
chris as much
and then when the popularity of
documenting chris i swear it feels like
it then became started going backwards
and this trolling's starting to get
worse again and
kind of coincides with the idea guys
song no the idea guys yeah guys what's
that it's a another group another
trolling group
which how many trolling groups are there
there's absolutely so many i just love
the names there's
there's a new one every month yeah okay
okay so the idea guys so the idea guys
were very detrimental to chris's psyche
because they convinced chris that all
these
different alternate realities alternate
dimensions of like
anime land and all these all these
cartoons actually existed and you could
travel to them
yeah they were the ones yeah okay yeah
so and to this day chris still believes
crystal believes that they can access
this different dimensions yes and chris
actually believed that at some points
they were possessed by like sonichu and
other other characters that they were
sonichu right right or something like
that like they were like it was it was
sanchez speaking through their body for
like a solid oh don't worry about it
don't worry about it
it's a battleman
all right i'm gonna eat out this is a
bit too much for me man
anyway um yeah
sonichu was
apparently talking through chris's body
for about half a year honestly it's just
like you can't explain like it's so hard
to keep up with this because even you
know when we watch the whole series in
depth it is so confusing and there's so
much stuff and we we've barely even
touched on the fact that one of the main
aspects of what chris was doing was
making a comic about sonichu and all
this stuff
that's what really started the whole
attention on chris because their comic
was so crazy and atlantis and people
realized that chris was actually using
the comic as a way to live out their own
fantasies
you know like uh
getting yourself inside like like a
self-made was it for sale for instance
yeah the main character was chris
basically so they believed they were
sonichu right yeah for a little bit and
then there was there were other
characters as well right from whatever
those like rose tunes rostro is
sonichu's love interest and wife yeah
yeah
and there's also i believe chris also
many points would include real people
that would die or yeah yeah
or something right
they would be the main villains but no
one actually died actually
in chris's comments because chris
believed that quickville was real
and they didn't want to cause that much
harm to their characters because they
would feel hurt
right right you know i really believe
that this i say right right
[Music]
also you know one other thing that i
also found uh very uh
worrying uh was uh
chris's spending
um and lack of financial uh okay where
did chris get an income from now i'm
curious chris has uh a social
security or
disability payment called which which
chris calls the tugboat
uh it's about 800 a month okay and this
is what
chris uses to uh pay off credit card
debts and
buy legos which brings him in which
brings chris into more debts right uh
chris gets money and immediately spends
it on like boys legos
yeah which is very disturbing because uh
i think chris's mother at the time
wasn't working either very old
and
they
yeah no one's been working in that
family since since the 90s i believe
right right right there's a very uh very
chilling video later on where chris is
getting uh their mother to
promote
chris's selling of merchandise yes and
saying that they need
uh money for food and stuff right
there's several videos like that it's
very concerning like merch is in like
what handmade merch by chris oh it's
like the sony truman aliens and stuff
like that right yeah there were
medallions there were um
signed photos i believe as well and
stuff like that yeah oh geez and it's
all very concerning it's the trolls that
are buying
that kind of stuff i mean just to like
fuel the fire i guess at this point are
they really trolls are they just like
almost like fans
it kind of sounds like a symbiotic
relationship yeah right where chris
feeds the trolls and there's trolls
yeah it just doesn't end yeah and by
acquiring
objects from chris they become part of
christopher in this yeah that's no no
that's serious these people are very
invested in them i love that song
i love
i i enjoy i really enjoy keeping up with
it but also i do feel like i'm consuming
something bad like
i am taking part and helping and fueling
a very dark side of the internet yeah
but it's also just so
insanely fascinating just because again
we've we've never had
anything like this in the history of the
internet i feel like it's it's so
it's so outlandish right like it's is is
it i'd argue in the history of the world
honestly like it's it's just so
everything about is just so outlandish
doesn't sound real because everything
that should have protected chris failed
right everything that should have been a
safety it feels like this this is almost
like a case study you know yeah of how
not to parent how how not to
how not to act on the internet
literally a case study of how not to do
everything yeah
it feels like anything about this just
don't do it yeah do you feel you know
when you're
because obviously you're making
documentary yeah how do you handle
dealing with like the i guess the moral
implications of it sometimes and
struggling with that if you if you do it
all like
i usually don't yeah you just like
whatever just power through yeah because
because i i can listen i convince myself
that i'm just documenting it's all right
i agree you know i i i don't
see what you're doing as anything
inappropriate or wrong by any means
right yeah because it's not like you're
like one of the trolls that's it's
like it's already existed out there but
i think by watching it in its entirety
or watching it in parts you really do
just end up feeling sad about the whole
situation yeah whereas i feel like if
you hear little bits
and and you get very tailored
information in a way that leaves out
important details
you might be more likely to participate
or fuel trolls to join in whereas if you
watch i feel like if you watch the
documentary there's no way you can be
sitting there thinking yeah i want to
join in control yeah you're just like
[ __ ] man jesus yeah definitely this
video is sponsored by final gear final
gear is a mech styled rpg that is set in
an apocalyptic world it'll soon be
released in the us europe and thailand
featuring over 100 gorgeous maiden
pilots for you to train and thousands of
powerful neck suits for you to unlock
assemble your mech as you wish with your
favorite pilots it's a side-scrolling
shooter game with real-time tactical
maps upgrade your base strategically to
achieve the final victory with greater
ease final gear with its plentiful
characters fascinating storylines
distinctive mech-related elements and
exquisite shooting style is loved by
loyal fans all over the world players
share tips and strategies and show off
their cool and powerful custom makes
every day we've also got plenty of gifts
and events in our game communities and
social media so what are you waiting for
download final gear now and don't forget
to use our code onscreen right now to
get some extra goodies final gear is the
all-new strategic rpg featuring mechs
and maidens remodel your max at your
will train tons of beautiful pilots and
tons of different occupations and
experience breathtaking mech battles a
journey featuring powerful necks and
beautiful pilots is about to begin
captain let's fight side by side the
game has also previously been released
in japan south korea and china and has
received tons of great feedback and it's
going to be released in september 30th
in the us europe and thailand one of the
main reasons i reached out to you and
asked you to come on the podcast is well
first of all i found out that you lived
in japan which is great very convenient
for us because we only let in-person
guests come on yeah uh in two obviously
there was some massive recent news yes
uh at the time of recording uh this will
be published a lot later um and i kind
of want to get into the most recent
history and obviously if people who are
sorry
come on sorry sorry i'm sorry every time
we say christopher gina is like
funny you dies it must be like whiplash
um you know like we said there was a
very big news and uh i guess let's talk
about the very recent his question sorry
uh about it because i i think the
viewers who don't know anything will be
intrigued uh or viewers who do know will
want a little recap maybe yeah um so
what would you say is like the very
recent where it began i guess or whether
ark or whatever if you will
so this all started at the end of july
of this year when a certain phone call
was linked with like a discord uh voice
chat it was like between chris and a
certain female party
a real female a real female by the way
an actual female who was actually
obsessed with chris right that's that's
that's a different female okay okay all
right there was someone who genuinely
like wanted to be with chris yeah he was
in this group
yes yes yes there was but this is a
different this is a very
disgusting female troll some female and
they were chatting away and chris
revealed very casually
how
how
their recent
development in their relationship with
with their mother was going
and how it started and how
when did this development start i guess
june or july of this year as far as we
know right yeah chris was yeah exploring
the mother's body
and um
this is actually sickening it's so
disgusting it's so disgusting
quite crazy but i remember when it
started everyone was like please say
psych like please say this is the joke i
remember that even the kiwi farms
members were like no no i'm sure there's
a mistake yeah um what was originally
leaked was a four and a half minutes
edit of the call which was very heavily
edited uh which which originally removed
all mentions of the female party in the
call so he didn't hear it at all so it
sounded very fake and edited so we
thought maybe like they're being
stitched together so yeah
to make it sound like that but no later
at another point like a nine minute call
was leaked with with the full contacts
and no chris was actually doing this
apparently i was i was hoping that that
chris was like astral projecting and
like
maybe in their mind having having
intercourse with the with their mother
in quickville just wanted to justify it
in any way that made it not really be
real
yeah i know i saw that argument quite a
bit when the news first broke out
because you know the whole thing of
chris you know with the whole quickville
thing being you know almost in this
delusional world right so i think the
biggest argument was that they just
imagined that they you know did stuff
with their mother but in reality we have
no proof kind of thing other than this
call obviously but yeah yeah chris was
talking about how at first
she said no
and how
and how she was very confused
but then apparently uh chris
satisfied her in a way that their father
never could
it's it's you can't make this up it's so
[ __ ] i actually feel physically safe
yeah i do i feel like it's disgusting
this this is like it's the most
disgusting episode
every bone in my body like i think this
is the worst and most like i definitely
feel we need to put a disclaimer at the
beginning of this episode we're gonna
have yeah yeah because yeah and and
what's more messed up is that this
all came out of chris's mouth as well
like this wasn't paraphrasing or
anything this was like
like their voice this is how proud i
think chris sounded very disturbed
and how almost
like happy
they were was very disturbing yeah and
it was just you know for every time you
you feel that chris understands
social norms or understands the
situation there's just another one that
slaps you in the face where you're like
chris has no understanding of what the
[ __ ] is right or wrong i feel
like i feel like i've heard serial
killer stories that are less disturbing
than some of the stuff i've heard right
right now like this is this is just
going like so many stages beyond what is
even like
comprehendable of what a human mind can
do you know it's uh
it's if someone wrote this in a story
they would be like unrealistic yeah i
know this is [ __ ] this is so stupid
no one would ever do this yeah and it's
just like it's just so sad and then also
uh chris later did is chris currently in
prison or jail currently in jail yes
because rightly so yeah incest charges i
believe for incest charges yes because
over 200 people called the local police
department
after that call was leaked and um chris
and their mother were actually first
separated you know um chris wentz chris
had to find some some other form of
accommodation for for a while while
their mother was being checked in in the
health center
and um yeah chris was at a hotel and
there were lots of people outside the
hotel recording and taking pictures and
like like like waiting for us for a
celebrity to come to come out of the
door it's disgusting
immediately found where yeah they were
staying right it's just disgusting these
trolls doing this like what's wrong with
you like what this is not something to
like try and get a scooper like this is
just tragic
and then and then the police came around
and chris was arrested publicly in front
of everyone and then chris said that the
merge was happening like like the merger
of dimensions of cartoon and reality
were happening and i was like chris
doesn't realize
what they're getting into yeah i mean i
actually
because you know when i saw the news
break out and i think there was a guy
who was live streaming the entire yeah
yeah yes it's a it's another lol cow
yeah yeah so one of the locals was live
streaming the arrest of chris
these guys seemed so pathetic oh yeah
absolutely pathetic human beings like
but like because like the guy was
shouting at chris like like a [ __ ]
paparazzi yeah being like how do you
feel like what wha what's going on in
your mind right now and of course you
know chris is just like smiling very
jovial throughout this whole what's so
disturbing is that throughout that
entire time where chris is talking about
you know the dimensions merging and that
they have you know like sonichu and rose
chew in their presence or whatever they
were saying the the entire time again
they were smiling like they have no idea
how much [ __ ] there is like yeah and
does did chris understand what being
arrested i don't i don't even think
chris understood what was happening
also i believe they were like plugging
their channel as well while he was well
i think yeah they were plugging the
channel
something like that yeah they're
plugging their channel a lot of places
it's like what
what are you guys doing there was so
much wrong with that live stream yeah
yeah i kind of just want to bleach my
ears yeah
like it was really hard to sit through
the footage but yeah my god it was
it wasn't yeah it was insane yeah as
[ __ ] as it is it's also super [ __ ]
the sheer amount of people that are
trying to just milk this for content
yeah um a lot of people just you know
were making really terrible clickbait
videos that were like 10 minutes that
didn't
include anything and would just just put
chris's name in the title because it was
a hot topic of course and i believe you
actually went on you announced a hiatus
yes so this happened yeah i was actually
originally playing hiatus anyway after
part 60 came out but in light of these
events i thought 59 is close enough so i
i released 59 i guess as scheduled maybe
a day after
the arrest or so and then i did a hiata
stream saying i'm going on break until
next year see you around yeah this is
because of the the yeah because uh
because i want things to cool down i
don't want to take advantage of the
situation so i'll yeah i'll back away
for a bit yeah i mean props to you
it'd be very easy to be like you know
what this is probably the highest search
terms the best seo for chris chan right
now you know it's everywhere every video
about christian's getting a million
views i could just pump it out right now
and get two mil but oh yeah props to you
man i i do and yeah that's that's big
boy move right there yeah oh yeah you
want a lot of uh respect points from me
for doing that uh this must have been a
tough call i'm sure a lot of people like
no release the next part tell us about
all the details actually most people
were very understanding really really
yeah actually that was very surprised i
mean i guess from the seriousness of the
situation yeah when it happened you know
did you get like a barrage of messages
and emails i did yes
they they're slow down for for now yeah
but i'd probably get two or three
hundred twitter dms saying i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry
it's like sorry for your loss
it's like a personal loss like a like a
family member or something
geez yeah is this the end then
do you think this is the end of the
story
it's very it's a very quiet part of the
story at least right but um
yeah since chris is in prison now or in
jail actually awaiting trial in
september i believe yeah there's nothing
coming out of chris not nothing at all
so it's very quiet it's just speculation
and discussion i i do hope the because
in courthouses in america you can just
turn up can't you if you're you can turn
up but i believe there's laws against
recording yeah you can't record yeah you
can you can write an account of what
happens i somehow have the feeling that
we'll get some audio recording i somehow
have a feeling that the trolls are going
to find a way they're going to find a
way yeah yeah i just it's going to be so
sad you know this is already disgusting
enough last thing you want it's like 20
trolls in the courthouse just like
giggling away
watching this all go down
i don't know it's
don't be that guy this is this is the
why this whole thing i say is a suspect
because anyone involved with this in
most in most capacity
you know there are a lot of people who
are out there trying to take advantage
in any single way they can get a quick
bar exactly exactly um
yeah it's just no man it's just nuts the
more i think about it i'm just like this
this would be the greatest told
fictional story of all time and then you
remember horus nothing is fictional
about this i think the most horrible
thing about this is that is this is real
yeah this is exactly actually like this
is this actually happened yeah it's
happened
in real life and it's just so well
documented
um and it's just like all these events
when you when you hear them separately
they sound like you know like that would
be the worst moment of somebody's life
right yeah somebody's like one of those
things and to think that that all came
from one person yeah that's why i think
you know people say most documented
person history i don't think that's
correct i think it's the most
embarrassing documentation of someone in
history
no one has taken as many owls as chris
no one has self-given that many hours
the sheer amount of disturbing stuff
that has been self-documented yeah you
know serial killers haven't reached this
level of [ __ ] up stuff yeah you know
we've had serial killers with more like
class than some of the stuff that chris
has been doing which is boring to say
yeah
honestly you know and i i again like the
whole situation is very sad yeah um i've
never wanted somebody to lose access to
the internet more than chris at many
points yeah yeah i mean you just
sometimes you see people online and you
just think you should not have any kind
of internet presence at all and i think
this is just
the worst example of just like what
everything that can go wrong and
everything that has gone wrong when i
found out that chris had a twitter i was
like oh no this oh you know i feel like
chris is well before this before this
drama happened recently chris had been
pretty tame online yeah um chris i think
it actually commented in one of our
videos what i believe so really
when we spoke about chris on trash taste
he's serious i believe chris had
actually commented on it and a very
normal comment right and chris had been
pretty
chill i'd say was pretty calm about most
of
until the [ __ ] storm happened it was the
calm before the storm right um what was
the arc before that then right before
that uh i feel like it was it was mainly
like a lot of people were hoping and
chris was it seemed was getting better
and that was generally calmed down a lot
and wasn't doing as many questionable
things
is that correct and saying yeah
definitely um
right before this happened there was a
certain book published
on amazon comparing andy warhol to
christian and um
why
because apparently there was a there was
a legit argument for that right there
was some
some interesting comparisons there i
actually had i was in contact with the
author before it was published and and
he gave me a like a advanced copy it
seemed pretty good i guess and you read
it through it oh i guess it was good i
didn't read too much of it though yeah
didn't have much time but chris
apparently did have enough time they
bought that themselves and they were
reading through it and uh
yeah they were enjoying it actually
that's what's weird is that chris
participates and consumes all the stuff
about themselves right i mean in a sense
there's like kind of a
kind of coolness to being compared to
someone like andy warhol right like as
much as like some weird [ __ ] andy warhol
has done in his life he's also like an
artist
yeah so like i think that chris would be
like oh cool
someone says i'm like andy warhol that's
kind of that's kind of it
what's what's uh most sad about this
whole story is that at any point during
chris's earlier life could have been
salvaged if their parents just took away
the [ __ ] internet right yeah take
away the ps5 something just do something
like a complete lack of parenting in
many ways yes yeah why why how on earth
was chris posting all this stuff online
you know and the parents had absolutely
zero knowledge how did that happen and
if they did have knowledge why the [ __ ]
didn't they stop any of this well maybe
because they're old age right it could
be maybe they're like a generation gap
they didn't understand the impact of i
don't think they understood the idea
i just feel like everyone in their life
has just failed chris yeah and it just
feels like now chris is now just a part
of that cycle as well yeah and well it's
what happens when your parents fail you
and you take you know you often pick up
you know i'm sure we've all done it or
you've picked up aspects of your parents
that you're like oh god i wish i didn't
pick that up yeah little things you know
but normally with most people it's
little quirks you know it's like or like
all like you know things you say yeah
yeah it's small behavior not you know
not life-destroying yeah habits most of
the time exactly um
yeah scary
it is a chilling tale about
uh parenting i feel most most the time
where do you think it all went wrong or
where do you think christmas failed the
most was it and how much blame do you
put on chris
that's tricky yeah
a lot of the blame goes to the parents
at the very beginning they uh encouraged
chris to uh
to see the world as against chris you
know because because chris had autism
and they were treated differently
because chris had autism and any action
that chris did
could be excused because chris had
autism right so so kind of uh so so
chris was raised with this understanding
that the world was bullying chris all
the time um
that's something you should teach to
your kid so so chris was given the
mindset of i'm always the victim but
also i can be excused for my actions
yeah chris um uh because their parenting
was so bad chris was mostly raised by
television by uh cartoons by
james anime games right by pornography
as well right uh chris learned most of
most of the outside world from those
sources and um
chris would often uh say things that
would be like cliche lines in a in a tv
show like um it takes a real man to to
admit his mistakes he would say that and
thinking that that would solve the
problem sounds cool in a tv show yeah
not so much in reality and and they were
infamously and they were infamously in
in their videos we do the the claw fail
as as they say like like this is a
threatening gesture right like a cartoon
villain yeah oh like
sam yeah like that
and always take off their glasses for
dramatic effects right right
it just feels like a lot of that is also
motivated by uh trying to have sex as
well
which is also caused by the media that
chris consumed like as this amazing goal
that that one must achieve uh chris once
stated in the video that that some of
the
like some of the life goals
were um
or driving to ohio which chris completed
playing the lottery which chris
completed and the virgin breaker was
still not completed yet so
chris was aiming to uh
take that off this felt like the
monkey's palm of wishing he
chris got the wish complete but yeah but
at what cost
i was gonna everything before before her
mother
did she ever lose her virginity yes
okay really prostitutes oh that's right
that's right i remember this the
prostitute arc of course of course i
remember that the very the
of course
the oldest profession in the world
obviously i i feel so bad for the
prostitute it's it's it is it is a
again you and you you present a scenario
and you pick the worst worst choice it's
like going through heavy rain pressing
nothing you know what i mean it's
literally the worst outcome and the
worst input in an rpg or something it's
you can't it's favorable just how many
bad decisions were made back to back to
back to back
and still
chris always found a way to get a
[ __ ] internet access yeah and it just
sucks right because you know they they
were given the choice and they always
picked the wrong choice and it's like
because no one was there to lead them in
the right direction right because the
trolls are the only ones who have come
together
and of course the trolls are going to
lead them down the wrong direction it
feels like in this in a in a way that
chris was raised by trolls you know
people being raised by wolves and
whatever
honestly because some of this stuff
sounds feral you know
it does almost sound on like that level
of just a case study where you have a
child that's just raised by wolves
except just replace the wall living in
the mountains replace
like the most like the lowest internet
trolls you can think of and this is this
is what you get yeah very unfortunate as
well that i think the time around chris
was raised was uh definitely like the
whole like american pie era of films
where sex was like the goal
if you were a young boy
16 it was like everything was about even
when i was growing up i'm sure you guys
felt the same everything in media was
like
get laid get like oh my god you're gonna
lose your virginity tonight at the prom
you know that's how it was you know yeah
um and as the movies would say it's
always at the third date yeah so chris
always specified that no sex before the
third day yeah
but i imagine if it came up in the
conversation i'm sure chris would have
been uh delighted uh
um yeah yeah to to add on the uh being
raised by by trolls thing chris was
actually given lots of reasonable advice
i guess by the trolls during that era of
2009-2010 like clean up your room and
stop and get a job and get at least a
part-time job in walmart for example and
um
trolls were trying to make chris realize
that sonichu could never make the money
because it was an amalgamation of
pokemon and
so yeah
they wanted chris to give up on that
fantasy and you know be uh be more
productive in society which chris
did not do but at this point chris had
never been made to have to do anything
that they didn't like chris had always
just doing whatever they wanted to do
right just want to play games all day
crystal play games all day so it's kind
of i think it's hard when you've gotten
to the age of
20 25 yeah and then you're suddenly told
hey don't play video games anymore don't
don't do these things online
yeah start working in nine to five
that's never gonna happen yeah you know
and and if
the person is never forced to do that
you know by parents or an external force
of course it's not going to happen i
only worked in mcdonald's because my
parents told me it was a good idea and i
wanted money yeah that's all i wouldn't
have done it
but what's so weird is that this those
same trolls who were telling chris to
you know get a job and clean his room
with the same trolls who were like hey
you should shove your medals yeah right
i mean like what do you think the trolls
wanted out of all this because just
entertainment probably entertainment
yeah and more signature comics at that
time they were really really looking
forward to the song she was like a hot
commodity at the time really
yeah uh as like an internet meme yeah um
and then now i feel like uh it's very
much flipped yeah yeah why was this why
did the sonic chew cop the comic like
gain popularity well
well because sonichu as a comic was
created first by chris when they were i
think from 21
from 21 years old and it looks like it's
drawn by someone considerably younger
like a
five-year-old for example
so chris didn't have the most amazing
art skills chris did not right or
storytelling skills better than me
any kind of skills honestly but so so
that's why um this uh ridiculousness
of the comics was the appeal for a long
time and also chris started to focus
more on the chris and quickville rather
than sonichu a lot of the times and uh
and beating and beating up
trolls trolls and the and the security
guards
yeah yeah
yeah whenever anything bad happened in
chris's life often it would be appearing
in the uh comic is like a kind of uh you
know when you get insulted and then you
go back home and you remember how you
should have responded right yeah it's
almost like that
instead of being like i should have said
that at the moment chris is like i'm
going to draw the scenario in which i
come out on top as the sigma right
it's uh it's the thought you have in the
shower yeah yeah shampoo bottles
clapping you yeah
and and during this time uh the trolls
were accusing chris of being gay which
chris did not agree with excuses very
homophobic at that time very homophobic
and very very straight according to
chris
so so to prove this chris drew an entire
episode of the comic where chris's
character sonic turned rose to have very
explicit sex
in this in the so-called comic how do
you prove you're not gay
that's how you do it clearly
my god that was a thing but then actual
because you know i understand like
sonichu and rose chew
not real ips right but then later down
the road weren't like actual ips used in
the in the like mewtwo
was a character right what yeah
eventually i guess i didn't go up to the
comics that that far well or i think
michael is only married to chris yeah
mutation
that's right mewtwo is married to chris
in the quickville dimension that's right
no no in this dimension
sorry god that's it
i also you know i feel like these
details aren't aren't important
right this isn't this is not an
important detail what did what is an
important detail i don't know i think
it's an important detail why why is it
an important detail because we have a
person who is like in this dimension
i am with mewtwo
let's go to a smash tournament
[Music]
why there's a difference between meaning
and being with mewtwo
very different
why mewtwo why
i don't know
hips
damn
damn i've never i've never looked at
mewtwo and i'm just like damn there's
child bearing hips yeah
of course
is that a boyfriend free girl
like is it is that is that what mewtwo
is yeah boyfriend free girl boyfriend
free girl is that in the pokedex
description of mutants you have no
gender no gender
yeah
you just crave how very progressive of
christ of course yeah
chris used to be anti-asexual so
anti-asexual yeah chris had a problem
with people who didn't want to have sex
right
the gay the gay people and the asexual
people too right because i believe that
chris was once rejected by a girl and
because she said that she was asexual so
actually at least twice but anyway the
mewtwo thing is because of the idea guys
right the uh previously mentioned trolls
which convinced chris that they were in
a relationship with both with
both throats three
there's there's three husbands and wives
mewtwo magic chance sonichu and chrysler
rose true
i'm very progressive i think
wait what was the second one
magic chan sonichu
which is which is that which is a
different character from the sonichu
comics magician
and they they put that idea in chris's
head
well yes
the marriage idea yes
wait why do they do this
what do they have to gain from it from
convincing chris that they were married
to mewtwo for the wolves
for the lols of course
this this sounds like the worst like
offspring of inception that i've ever
seen
this is literally the worst inception
movie yeah
that's a very a very uh troublesome
account during the idea guys saga where
the idea guys convinced chris that they
were holding crystal rose to their their
love interest at the time hostage and
they were torturing her so in order to
stop them from torturing her chris was
forced to do many other things such as
film videos
like urinating on the floor and then
having like on a carpet or like a
laminated wood floor
i think it was the carpet oh for [ __ ]
again the worst choice [ __ ] man like oh
okay
i think was the carpet because i didn't
get to that part in the dock so
i'll get to it later but anyway yeah so
then then chris was was told to have
pretend sex with a pillow while all-star
by smash mouth played in the background
i'm sorry that's that's just funny no
it's terrible it's almost funny to think
about but then at the same time
it was like you know it was the same
choice
it was disgusted and for some reason i
heard all-star smash mouth and i'm like
other and another trolling group at a
later point leaked these these videos on
chris's on twitter right um yeah but
anyway also the idea guys managed to
extort over six thousand dollars out of
chris
um
okay that's not cool that's not cool
yeah and um this is where the owner of
the qb farms and and another elite group
of former trolls got together
and contacted elite yeah let's get elite
royal guards
put in the special forces what is an
elite troll we're an hour and a half in
and we never even mentioned the man in
the pickle suits i can't believe this
wait what how could we forget the man in
the pickle suits
oh of
course this was an earlier trolling
attempt back in 2009
2008 2009 where chris went on a
real-life date if you will with a female
troll posing as a girlfriend
who was then
yeah who was who was then uh snatched
away by a man in the pickle suit because
chris
hated pickles because it reminded them
of penises of course they're super
straight so right
yeah that's why not that he doesn't like
eating pickles
oh they hate pickles too all pickles
eaten or just seen anyway
anyway the guy behind the pickle suits
costume uh is actually the administrator
of the quickie
and he's one of the moderators on the
christian forum on kiwi farms so he's
like a big shot still wait wait so so a
dude in an actual pickle suit arrived
yes during the day yes and took the girl
yes
you know what if if that happened to me
i'd probably be [ __ ] drunk at levels
as well this is so early on that i think
i've forgotten this is part 11 by the
way clearly a rick and morty fan yeah
so this what does it have to do with the
elite trolls uh so
the man in pickle suit and the owner of
the kiwi farms and another another troll
got together and seized chris's discord
account which was used to communicate
with the idea guys and from there they
found all this information
and um they found then the addresses and
names of the idea guys and tried to
report them to the fbi actually
because this was uh extortion of money
across across state lines so it was a it
was a federal offense right yeah so they
even called the idea guys mothers
uh
to no avail uh i mean because i assumed
they were all children right
teens at least or maybe early twenties
get the [ __ ] out of them though probably
i think they uh stopped after after that
oh yeah but yeah there was there was no
case against them uh chris is still out
six thousand dollars geez well they were
out until
until a gofundme was established by the
owner of the kiwi farms to get chris a
plane ticket and uh to to go to a my
little pony convention in california oh
yeah they raised over five thousand
dollars and like maybe less than the
week after that was the phone call
concerning chris's mother right they're
about to just go to the my little pony
because they were obsessed with my
little pony and uh
because of course and the sonic series
and i remember there was a whole series
of chris complaining about sonic and the
new series
right
that was back in 2014. god damn there
was also like the my favorite like troll
who was like the
probably the most talented role like the
liquid crisp one is that what it's
called that's very good we should just
go in chronological organizations i
skipped everything i'm just i'm i'm
sorry because it's not really that
important to the story but also this
the liquid chris is probably my favorite
part because it's probably the most
tasteful
of this i love as well how every time a
point is brought up you you say the the
date like it's like a real historical
event is 1945 germany
december 2014. when it all happened and
i know how people feel when one piece
fans talk about their arcs now it's like
oh yeah the the big mom
i'd say the only the only like tasteful
troll in my opinion with the liquid
chris yeah uh where someone did a
spot-on impression of chris's uh speak
the speed yeah
very good yeah and
filmed videos as chris
and taunted chris uh by like
saying they were the real chris
and it was very it was very very well
done right and the the way that they
would speak is like it's very good right
yeah yeah and they would they challenged
chris to like a sing-off or something
yes
how this started was liquid chris as as
he became referred to uh actually
started posting videos on youtube as
chris just for the entertainment of his
friends yeah and then after a while
trolls noticed this and
wrote emails to chris about it saying oh
this guy's trying to steal your identity
you should probably address this and
this is how they they became involved
with each other and um to prove to prove
who was the real chris uh they would do
several things like for for example the
real i mean the actual real quest chris
or solid chris as they were referred to
at this time
literally the plot to metal gear
i'm not
so anyway solid chris posted their like
real address their phone number
proving it was them yeah
so why
because they were the real they were the
real ones only they would know chris
it's like that meme of like someone who
when it's like hacker who knows my
address me who knows it longer
it's literally that me yeah
so yeah and then after that chris saw
solid chris decided that that the best
way to to go about proving this was to
do a a sing star challenge where they
would pick three songs for the other to
sing or was like right
or something like that but anyway
um the best singer
would um would be voted uh
the champions [ __ ] american idol
how chris chose this that's what's
and they um
amazing because liquid chris was
actually a pretty good singer
i'm very good at playing guitar playing
guitar so like i actually like just
killed the songs
and chris was terrible
that's what was so amazing about it is
that it was so funny oh my god yeah
and then uh yeah and after the contest
was over according to a technicality
liquid chris one and then and then
they decided to to call it quits and and
leave and uh according to the liquid
chris storyline on on youtube
he went out to get married with his with
his girlfriend and then and then go to
uh richmond
and uh make like join nintendo and make
a sonichu game for example
yeah and then chris was very angry with
that because they weren't the ones
making the song machine right yeah the
fake christmas it was very well done
trolling actually it was like where
you're like okay trolling isn't too bad
sometimes very tasteful very funny that
just seems like the tasteful prank yeah
basically because there's no
repercussions in there right it's just
good fun i was getting hurt i feel like
that is just good content yeah that's
good content i mean solid chris was very
angry it produced really
entertaining videos like life ruining
things yeah it's just not extortion of
money or anything like that right
exactly compared to the other stuff like
oh wow something somewhat tasteful yeah
right and then obviously there was the
whole saga uh with chris and uh sonic
and chris and sonic yes so well like the
real sonic sonic the hedgehog right yes
not the fast food chain yeah that's
that's the difference sonic anyway this
sonic um this was in relation to the new
sonic game at the times
sonic boom sonic boom that's it yeah the
the new tv show and game
which was um which of course featured
very wild redesigns of the characters
yeah including a sonic the hedgehog with
blue arms
which was incredibly offensive to
christine right right incredibly
offensive oh my god
um
they were very angry right crystal rant
on facebook and they would demand that a
gamestop would stop selling sonic boom
um they would even buy sonic boom
merchandise
and break it apart and like paint and
repaint their their arms tan
um jesus and
they encouraged the boycott of sonic
boom even though they they were
purchasing sonic boom toys themselves
so yeah and then of course
they went to a gamestop
and they and they tried to change the
sonic boom um game game covers with with
one saying please don't buy this game
sonic's arms are not blue and chris was
banned for that
and then chris went back again
uh around christmas 2014
and then
they were kicked out again but during
this point someone noticed that chris
was there they started filming a short
video on their phone and on their way
out chris pepper sprayed a gamestop
employee
[Music]
it just doesn't sound real one thing i
want to know is has chris ever had like
a single
real
friend
in their life
have they ever have they had ever had
like an actual human connection i guess
there are gal pal from the game store
which chris chris ruined that with that
with that image right yeah probably that
so that was probably the one time where
they had somewhat of a chance yeah
because because she actually had um
the friend actually had a brother who i
think was also on the autism spectrum so
she was more understanding of of chris's
needs
right yeah
but obviously not that understanding
yeah pretty much everyone in chris's
life failed chris in every single way
which makes this a very tragic story i
mean it's
just it's sick it's [ __ ] up and it's
also sad right because it just seems
like chris has just never had like a
proper human connection
in their life
and yeah that's that's you know that's
that's pretty [ __ ] because everyone
needs like a real human connection and
if the only connection you're getting
and the only communication you're having
is with internet trolls i'm not just
like light internet trolls but like i
think i would lose my mind if i had that
yeah yeah yeah exactly i i would
actually go insane which i think chris
is right now which might explain why
chris is so involved in this whole
dimensional merge thing and why and why
chris project um astral projects into
into into these different cartoon
dimensions like hyper dimension neptunia
was also very very big for chris you
never want to assume someone's mental
well-being uh but you have to have great
concern yeah when you see the stuff that
chris says of late i was very involved
with
and uh even though it seemed harmless
you have to wonder
why what had to go wrong right someone
to believe this stuff right
obviously in the case with chris
everything yeah it's uh yeah i remember
there's also many points with the sonic
thing where uh chris was demanding uh
like
like getting responses or something from
sonic or something
was there a point where they they
chris was very angry because chris
thought that they included chris in the
show
yeah there was a
chris actually did not think so but
everyone else thought so because there
was this uh this character on the sonic
boom tv show
which was a crazed sonic fan which
looked a lot like classic christian and
uh trolls thoughts or like observers of
chris thought it was chris but
but chris
denied it and um you know
yeah it's very very similar wow and i i
remember they would uh chris would spam
voice actors a lot of like my little
pony and stuff and
just demand them to i couldn't i don't
even want to do what just weird demands
like yeah just on twitter all the time
yeah this was this was because chris met
them at uh at the my little pony
convention monica royale right monica
real that was a long time ago that was
2004 actually
before the internet thing really
kicked off but yeah
um
yeah chris was in contact on twitter
with these voice actresses because they
showed compassion for chris during their
meetups at the mlp convention
i guess tipped chris
chris could not let go yeah
like i i know
i shouldn't be dumbfounded because this
is a podcast
and you know we need to keep talking but
like i i genuinely don't even know what
to say
that this has just been me like the past
half hour yeah right like i'm trying to
add on to the conversation anything i
just don't don't even know what i want
to say like where where'd you go from
here
surely there must be many points where
you're like [ __ ] i can't do this i can't
keep documenting this [ __ ] like
like has there ever been points where
you've just legitimately gone like nah
yeah when i stopped making part 13
originally i went on a break for like
about nine months or so right then came
back with 2.1 well i mean like anything
that chris themselves actually did that
made you go i don't want to document
this i mean the closest thing was the
was the recent events right yeah which
encouraged me to go on a break right
yeah because you were saying
yeah because you were saying that the
court case was september right september
16th was yeah so probably by the time
this episode comes out we might have
new information about it right at this
point but at this point i just want the
story to end like the story needs to end
i just hope the judge just never lets
chris have any internet connection
that's what i yeah yeah yeah but i i
also worry the trolls have probably
found a way to do something
it seems like this has led very clearly
into real life i mean it obviously has
with uh trolls uh showing up at chris's
house yeah and it's just
i i don't know it's like it the line has
been blurred so much that there is just
no line anymore
um
yeah it's just the wild west isn't it
it's like now it just kind of seems like
this is the [ __ ] you would expect to
hear on the deep web or something yeah
but no it's it's right here in front of
us for a lot of people
um scary some of the most disturbing
things i've ever heard
uh in my life uh
probably uh
especially coming out of the internet
and uh
yeah like i just this this this story
needs to end i thought i've heard a lot
of [ __ ] up stories from the internet
and then i'm hearing all this today and
i'm just like jesus yeah it's not good
it's really not good you know one thing
that uh i have to wonder is quite
difficult um as i've experienced some
something similar myself is uh you know
when you're a creator who makes
something and often
a certain type of video is it difficult
you know being stuck in the category of
the guy who talks about chris chen is
that is that something you struggle with
yes yeah yeah
i think the word you're looking for is
pigeonholed yeah because you know i i
had a similar thing when i started my
youtube career where i was only doing a
certain type of uh video on a certain
type of anime
and it was like all i was known for yeah
it was what everyone referred to me as
that guy who does x video
um at least your username isn't that
like me true yeah joey's called the
anime man
so i'm kind of [ __ ]
he doesn't watch anime anymore
that's the biggest lie yeah the biggest
lie on youtube it's the man now
you know
is there is there any
you know
is there like a plan do you have
something you want to try and
branch out to oh yeah um actually my
channel is called geno samuel 2 0.1
because it's
actually originally my second channel so
my first channel is devoted to music
original and covers so that's that's
what i've been doing a lot longer than
the christian stuff
as far as japanese things go i guess i'm
most most well known for doing a cover
of plastic love which kind of oh you did
i did i did got over a million views so
it's oh [ __ ] wow nice that's that's my
other thing that i'm known for i guess
nice you know for plastic and christian
yes
so very different things
yeah
also there's the general samuel 3 which
is where i post uh documentaries that
are not about chris chan
right you did one about uh yokai right i
do a series about yokai yeah
shortish videos about yokai and uh hope
to branch out onto other topics yeah
nice yeah would you like japanese
folklore and uh
culture and stuff like that well i
assume you are
you're in japan
uh mostly focused on yokai uh other
other docs will be about different
topics yes wide range people people are
pretty wondering why are you in japan
what brings you to japan well i've been
interested in japanese culture for a
very long time and i started teaching
the language myself actually when i was
still in school i was learning the
the writing systems and reading and
writing myself and then
and then i got into a course in
university which allowed me to do a year
abroad study in tokyo or in japan i
didn't know if i was going to tokyo at
that time but yeah so that allowed me to
to experience japan and then decided to
come again and work as an english
teacher
nice so yeah that's where i am now
spent a year in hokkaido which was
i don't know i don't know
i mean i mean i love hokkaido
i've only been on like vacations there
exactly exactly if you have to live
there for a year in a very small town of
5000 people it's quite a different
experience which is the majority of
towns in hokkaido like most of hokkaido
is pretty desolate yeah did you you
couldn't talk to anyone i actually was
very little yeah my japanese skills are
not that good and um
everyone's english skills are also not
that good so i was kind of stuck in a
rut um i was employed by the um by the
city hall or the town hall so then i
would provide english lessons to all the
schools
in the town which is like three of them
so yeah preschool uh primary school
secondary school hard the junior high
school so yeah everyone knew me everyone
looked at me everywhere i went you're
the guardian i'm the engineer
at that point you are just the token
foreigner yeah right
[Music]
i did yeah i eventually got used to it
and i
enjoyed the uh
enjoy the fun of it i got used to it
it sounds like an acquired touch yeah i
mean yeah
it was it was tough at the beginning of
course and of course hokkaido has some
very gruesome winters
yup actually almost died at one point
which was what what
in the winter uh yeah um i was i was at
school and we were caught by a by a
blizzard a very terrible blizzard and we
had to send all the all the kids home
and all the staff home i i had to walk
home of course i didn't have a car
um
over along along the course of the walk
i got really cold obviously and there
was snow getting in my boots and my feet
were freezing which was not good uh i
could barely walk because of the wind
and the snow when i got to my house i
could not open the front door because it
was frozen shut oh my god because the
because the door frame was metal
together
so i decided to go back out and go to a
convenience store to buy like an
electric lighter
in the in a van attempt to to try and
heat up the door and melt the ice along
the way i got really sleepy and i
thought oh no maybe i should i should
take a rest i really wanted to do that
but then this one's like hypothermia
it is hypothermia man i thought i
thought i was gonna lose my feet but
yeah i managed to struggle my way back
home and pulled as hard as i could
because of course in japan you have to
pull the front door open not now push it
in pushing it yeah yeah which very
difficult in that sense but yeah i
actually
managed to open it after a while and
heat up crazy stuff [ __ ] did you have
any lasting side effects from that were
your feet okay i'm okay yeah
just like yeah you feel black
i can't walk anymore
i imagine i was very close but yeah
because i i could not feel anything
there wasn't there was no sensation of
like touch at all you just wanted to
teach english
you started to live in japan you wanted
to teach english right man what's the
teaching was always loser's feet
so how long been in japan for um
on enough about four years uh spent a
year as a
study abroad student in tokyo and then
uh when you're in hokkaido two years in
tokyo as an english teacher for an after
school
thing
yeah how much you have to like speak
japanese in the in your class or do you
use it for your work at all uh zero is
there japanese for us yeah really it's
an all-english environment yeah oh so
all the kids are speaking english oh
yeah oh wow is it like a cram school
kind of thing not a not a cram school
kind of like a after school almost like
a daycare so if you will so you never
get a chance to improve your japanese
right yeah
that's what people always people are
always online when you talk about living
in japan like oh my god you're not
fluent in like one year what the [ __ ]
yeah and it's like you don't understand
when when you're here to do certain
things you don't get the opportunities
that a normal person
would would get living here you have to
go without a job as well well right like
we're always talking with like english
speaking staff yeah people overseas and
stuff like that so it's very rarely that
you know you have to actually talk to
japanese people unfortunately like it
sucks because you can't just
unfortunately just absorb it via osmosis
you actually have to uh get this go out
and put effort into learning yeah you
kind of have to learn it
yeah it's
it's a thing which uh you do which uh
most of us hate it in school yeah as an
adult you have to choose to put time in
it because like one thing one thing that
you don't really think about is how much
time you have to put into actually
learning an activity and like you have
to put time and effort into it whereas
as an adult i don't think it's any
harder to learn a language it's just
harder to find time right to commit to
it yeah like in a perfect world i would
just i would want to take like a year
off of my life just to like fully commit
to learning japanese but i can't i have
a job and i have commitments you know
and uh i think as an adult that's just
much more harder to do yeah
so you've always been really creating on
youtube for quite a while really yeah
creating in general yeah i'm a
compulsive creator right so is there
like a next step of what you want to
achieve after you're done with this
documentary
uh interesting that you say that because
i did actually uh come in contact with
two
two producers involved with um creating
content for for example streaming
services or even hollywood actually
concerning
christian obviously oh wow but but yeah
so so they've seen my work and and um
of course they see they see dollar signs
after
after this recent debacle yeah so
but yeah so we're interested in maybe
creating something i'm i'm not sure yet
if it's possible but yeah either
um american network or netflix amazon
maybe streaming i don't know about uh
christian christians oh like like a
feature well honestly it could be we
you know true crime is all the rage
right now
this is now a true crime
unfortunately this is like
this is a netflix level story like it's
like an avengers level threat
making a making a murderer looks like a
joke
this is like making uh making a
christian yeah
honestly this black mirror thought it
was dark
yeah until this stuff we could have a
five-season netflix show about this yeah
honestly justice it's
oh my god yeah that would be very cool
yeah
i'm just curious how how much longer do
you think it would take to uh catch up
to catch up to the story because you're
at what 2017
2017 yes
november 2017. uh part 60 we'll we'll go
into 2018 finally
so maybe another 10 another 10 episodes
yeah maybe this is like the anime
adaptation that catching up to the manga
right
when it catches the manga what happens
do we delay the episodes stop yeah what
happens
yeah it's
it has to be
i don't even know how i would feel uh
being in your shoes i don't know
you know i'm sure one hand i really want
this to conclude
on the other hand i'm like oh god what
am i going to do after this
exactly yeah uh yeah i i guess you know
other than the movies or any other
future plans that you have or creating
stuff or music do you want to be done
with this yeah it's a good question yeah
kind of
but
but if the opportunity arises like for
example if i if i if i can get something
done with netflix like i can get my name
up there this could be like a stepping
stone a stepping stone right yeah yeah
yeah exactly i mean i feel like now
you must be the go-to guy for
information about this as they say i am
the christian guy
you just you've you've been the only
person who has been able to present it
in a way that
it doesn't make you feel like you're in
some weird internet forum kind of like
finding out about a guy who you
shouldn't be looking at yeah
you know whereas i feel that the videos
very much presented
like we said in an objective way that
makes you not feel
too bad for consuming it whereas i feel
like if you're reading it online you're
like this is weird yeah like i shouldn't
be here kind of things yeah yeah i don't
know this was wrong like i'm fueling
this right yeah um yeah well i mean i
wish you the best of luck i i really
want to see what else you can do i i i'd
be interested in what other
documentaries you could pull off yeah uh
god knows that you've proven your your
uh your dedication to your subject i
think no one can question that when you
go deep on a subject
you know if someone's making a
documentary about anything i like get
gino right yeah that man has gone in
hard
you know
massive props to you man i have
absolutely massive respect for the sheer
amount of work you've put into this and
i
you know i don't think i've put one
tenth the amount of effort into
something in my life so i mean congrats
i guess
thanks i'm going to go and watch the
rest i promise you should i'm sure i'm
not like episode 10 right now i've only
got what like 50 episodes to catch up on
it's all right i can do it if i catch up
on one piece i can catch up on this yeah
i was about to say i i caught up on one
piece like i'm gonna catch up to the
rest of you you should watch it it is
very compelling it's very well done
gino's done an amazing job and of course
links in the description to all of
gino's channels yes check out his music
as well and uh yeah third channel where
he does documentaries and stories about
yokai right mm-hmm damn don't you want
to plug yourself anymore anything else
you do yeah i'm good
well there you go then yeah man oh gino
man thank you so much for coming on this
has really been a pleasure
and uh
what was i going to say this is for the
most different episode of trash taste
we've ever done it's been an
enlightening episode yeah eye opening to
say the least this is probably the least
tangent we've ever talked in an episode
yeah right this it's almost a themed
episode in a sense
but yeah i've just it's definitely been
an educational episode uh i don't know
if i've wanted to be educated
but
now i am apparently
um but it has also been fascinating yeah
super fascinating
yeah i don't know what else to say it's
it's probably been like the episode
where i've found it the hardest to talk
yeah right
sometimes i'm just like how do i even
react to this stuff yeah it's other than
making a just dumbfounded face it's just
gonna be like me making youtuber
reaction faces throughout like two hours
of this
we should get all the thumbnails just
like the thumbnail just looks like yeah
just use just use me and gone for
thumbnail faces because we made so many
of this episode just listening to these
stories
it's absolutely insane is there anything
you'd like to say to the viewers before
we uh end this any final thoughts final
thoughts um
christian's story is very very
complicated
and
it can
it can serve as a lesson
for for many things in life serve as a
lesson what not to do on the internet um
how to um how to behave in in-person
relations as well um
it can
well basically uh
see it and think for yourself because
that's what i really encourage with my
series is that you make your own
decisions i'm not going to tell you what
you think
yeah thank you for bringing such a good
moral to this absolute [ __ ]
yeah
yeah but yeah let's thank the patrons as
well
before we forget oh my god sorry
patience you're in this room you have to
have your name on this yeah
but hey if you'd like to support the
show then make sure to go over to our
patreon patreon.com also follow us on
twitter send us your memes on the
subreddit and if you hate our face
listen to us on spotify and thank you
gina for coming along yeah thanks for
having me yeah all right bye
check out check out juno's channel bye
[Music]
you